コーン日ま行為3いやの映画をいただき今4多い
今日は外れしたそうですみんなそこ何に憧れたことがあるだろうか倉庫のキョロちゃん
も空を飛びたいと思っていた時期があった世の中にいる様々な生き物が2練習もが
飛ぼうと思ったことがあると僕も思いたいと思っているところである
c ネクタイちょっと落ち着こう1回落ち着かごめんな
うんめっち東京だからさこれ共同学本命なんだよ
もう俺だーッ
はぁ
[音楽]
ブーバーみんなアポロぜーしょんについてきてくれ
競争アティヤーこちらブーブー言っロスが昔あったぱぱぱーと3
やって空を飛ぶ系ですやっぱそれをと時計のことだって面白いですよ結局これすごいな
もうなんかまるで本物のたりのようにと病って書いてありますサイズに着替えたら
捕まえらみたいな感じで中郷が鳥を撮っ捕まえようとしていますね
すぐに電池がいらないんだって usb 充電できるこれはありがたいです本物と
りっぽくと打って言われたらそれがこっちもこっちで気になってくるので早速開けて
みるよ
ああああああ
[音楽]
いうか遊び方はフレーズあるでは10 s be friends 充電していきます
いや実際でも普通に楽しみだよなぜ空飛ぶんでしょ線その飛ぶのでテンションはから人
にはいないと思っているまずは電源を入れてください
入っファイナルファンド者の選ぶ時の音が電源を入れたら本体よく金を止めてください
頭を2回押すと抑えずたり立ったりします
んだっ
あ
抜いて泣いてるだけだよ
老舗いぽぽとこ行かれた方いぞ
あとの3回連続で叩くと8大企業と同じ木飛び立つらしいです
マジすごい上つ
wh
ran だあああああああ
me
[音楽]
judge me
4段階で劇的な
[音楽]
大
おおーー
ほななぁ何ワロタ
まっチャーター
[音楽]
ana 数
はいというわけで実はさん品は裁判で搭載日中で飛ばして終わろうところ
います e to one g queen
ああ
yeah
car
やめろ
me
ええええええ
teame
ni
ええええええ
バッハ
つい2ワンクリック
ana